so today's question is what do you and I
have in common with candles
so recently I was having a conversation
with a couple of my buddies on the golf
course regarding why some people get
content with life and the bigness of
life they just kind of start you know
plain of small life rather than
everything that they can do and I said
you know we have a lot of similarities
with a candle let me explain to you why
everybody can be lit up so if you think
about every one of these candles each
one of them represents a longer time for
a person to stay excited so if I'm
trying to light up the small candle here
I can light it up I can light up the
second big one then we can go to the
third one as well as the fourth one so
if this is a source of being lit up
being excited being fired up there all
right now lit up right and yes have you
ever inspired another person to do
something big with their lives think
about that believe it or not you and I
have been a source of inspiration for
another person Buddha once said
thousands of candles can be lit up from
a single candle therefore the life of
the candle will not be shortened because
you are always going to be remembered as
the person that inspired somebody else
to make a big decision in their lives so
now that we know that you and I can
inspire anybody the next question
becomes why do most people not stay
excited until their dream becomes a
reality think about that I work with a
lot of people on a daily basis but why
don't most people stay excited all the
time you know why do most people on
mistake sigh oh I'm gonna go out there
and do this I'm gonna get in shape I
want to do whatever it may be it's a
it's a very short life span right and
some is the second third fourth so the
question comes down to is well you got
to ask yourself is which of these
candles are you how long do you
typically stay excited how easily are
you discouraged in life how easily do
you give up in life because you may say
Patrick you know what do I do and
sometimes someone's right and rains on
my parade what do you mean well somebody
tells me you know it just doesn't work
out or I can't do this this is what
happens you're turned off right but what
do you need to do all you need to do is
go find another candle friend be around
it and they light you up anybody can do
this but in order to do something
with your life you do need to stay lit
up till your dream becomes a reality
that's my message of the week to you and
please be sure to subscribe and share
this video
you